joining us now of the Los Angeles Rams
is Lyman Andrew Whitworth how are you
Andrew
I do a riskless happy to be alone with
you well I'm happy that you're on and I
appreciate you coming on it's such a
crazy time where are you literally right
now
calling in all right literally driving
back to all those notes to try and just
on it before visiting facilities well
thought out the Colorado today okay is
your home standing best to your
knowledge yeah yeah yeah we're just kind
of surrounded by some of the fires and
are still in the minute or you back
until that can kind of make sure all
that stuff's out based off the winds
today so hopefully I'm gonna get to move
home tomorrow Tuesday and it's our
Wednesday but will you know we're just
kind of watching the weather hope that
we could clean and you're leaving with
the team later on this afternoon to fly
to Colorado to get used to I guess the
altitude in advance of the game in
Mexico City is that correct yeah that's
right we're leaving ahead out there and
do some altitude do all our work at
altitude this week to kind of adjust
well how does that make you feel to be
honest with you I mean what what's going
on between your temples right now andrew
is as all this is happening with you
getting set to leave town for a week and
the country eventually well yeah I mean
it's it's obviously a trying week for us
it really has this name issue deeds of
it everything that developed Thursday
throughout the day with the fires you
know an emotional time for all of us for
all the guys as always tell me gossip
you know we're been before where
anything in that were people before were
players you have to have that kind of
boat so we make your decisions and you
know so it's definitely been something
pulling hard over the heart this this
past week everything on us and the
community of people that we live with
and see every day and so it's been a
tough and you know really to have this
when we all have to leave now today with
a lot of us trying to figure out how to
make sure our families who settles and
face all that I mean it's obviously it's
not an easy thing to do but it's part of
what we do so
so you know we'll do what's best for
Andrew Whitworth Rams offensive tackle
here in the Rich Eisen show how many of
your teammates and colleagues and
front-office folk have been evacuated
best your ability knowledge with the
Rams from what I understood is a little
over 40 different families that were
evacuated and you know it you know
awesome videos were you know anywhere
between five at the border Thursdays and
overnight Friday early I guess you'd say
no no it's part of what quite a weekend
for sure because postal families like
for us for example were evacuated about
2:00 in the morning I think by the time
we got to the hotel and really got all
four of our kids so then laid back down
is about 4:30 so it's kind of those
deals where I was getting ready like hey
I guess obsesses having facility we get
there about 6:00 in the morning but we
ended up canceling Friday just because
so many families were displaced people
that work for us and so you know it was
definitely a that's for sure but I think
none of us have ever been through and is
it true Andrew the Rams front office
told everybody just do what you have to
do we got we've got the received the
receipts and we've got it is that a fact
yeah things work well and work to top to
bottom over the top is in help of
themselves in that kind of way just and
it makes it so much easier I want the
trickle down think you're right while
you carry themselves right way so it uh
you know there's various fun when I just
tell you know don't worry don't fret
don't go back and get your family safe
get some more secure will take care of
you Andrew Whitworth again here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so let's get to the
the I it's just man it's just crazy you
know because I know a ton of people who
have had to be evacuated and have lost
their homes and they talk about how it
just feels like an apocalyptic scene
with ash raining you know raining down
and and and and but there's only one
community in Thousand Oaks that was torn
apart before the fires
due to senseless gun violence I mean and
you donated your game
check to the folks who have been harmed
by the gun violence in Thousand Oaks why
did you do that Andrew well family the
people that every day you see a or
another either needing shopping at
community the grocery store for bogey
sitters evil kids that we know their
kids go to school with these are people
that live while we see all the time if
you're part of the kid you know somebody
that is it leadership like I ever the
captain of our football team and talk to
the guys all the time just football
stuff for just life stuff well being who
they are you can't get out of the guys
your communities hurting it so to be it
was like hey I know I have to play a
football game I still got to prepare it
this time we didn't have the fire stuff
yet started so I was like what's
something I could do right now the
moment you just say hey we're in this
with you my wife went visited a lot of
people's individuals else my Danny
Krista who's a lesson suppose was long
given blood and doing things we just
tried to be active and so I'm gonna text
my wife's I just said hey look I think
another way we can do this is just
inspire some people that weren't wearing
this with others that this week we
should just give our game check to these
families and play for free because the
reality is this is something we can do
to just inspire hopefully put on arms
around people obviously this is Lisa
don't people know that were with them
it's honestly it's a pretty easily the
Ventura County Community Foundation's
kanae Ovalle Victims Fund for anybody
out there that wants to perhaps follow
suit with Andrew I mean can you voice
what the folks in Thousand Oaks are are
thinking right now
Andrew people talk about you know this
he was like consider water laughing
one of the nicest and safest communities
in the country just a year or two ago
for it to happen here I think it's just
one of those you sit there you know it's
a horse this is really to escape it is
that there the truth is you know this is
everyone and the potential of these
anywhere and you can't read you can't
hide from it all you can do is try to
perform yourself in charge you know
doing over you can honestly - we can -
getting somewhere this stuff starts
happening and you know you can't take
what you're safe in boys need to be
alert understand
we saw the beverage like I mean you know
you're so confused or kids need to go to
school like right beside where this
happened do we send our kids to school
or not it's over but chaos support yes
no can also just hey it what age do we
start telling them okay this is how
things are in the world today and put
you out with your friends and places you
know it's just that side reality and
maybe this is at a young age just start
talking to them about which is
unbelievable it's the truth Andrew
Whitworth Rams offensive tackle your big
dude and I don't know how you're holding
your phone but we're catching only one
out of every few words that you're
saying so in the few minutes we have
left here with Andrew Whitworth let me
ask you this
look you play football for a living if
we all could do it we would do it you
make a nice chunk of change out of it so
I say that only is the caveat a lot of
folks out there that obviously would say
well he's a football player so that's my
caveat how are you getting through it
how are you and your teammates getting
through all of this playing a game okay
we're obviously your livelihoods online
so is your health and on top of it
you've got Super Bowl wishes that you
could bring home to a community that
you've just described certainly could
use that sort of distraction how are you
handling all of this with your teammates
Andrew
I think you just continue to challenge
each other that we're made for this I
mean you know as players that's one of
the things I encouraged our team with
when I talk to them Thursday after the
shootings was that you know what we
played one of the few jobs that yeah
it's an amazing job and we get
financially rewarded very well for it
but every single Sunday we face another
force of another group of people that
are extremely talented and really good
and we're playing through all kinds of
injuries we're playing through a lot of
adversity and if anybody should be able
to understand adversity and handling
pain and playing through it for one
common goal it should be NFL athletes
and so that was one of the things I
encourage the guys it's important for us
to stand up and be strong and show the
community that we're within it with them
and that maybe if there's just something
we can do in the way we carry ourselves
the way we help the community what we do
to support them if we can in some way
inspire them that they can do it they
can get through it we that we're right
there with them we're gonna stand beside
them and help them through it any way we
could just do that whatever that was it
didn't have to be financially it could
be just do your work through your hands
and feet man just going out in the
community just whatever way you could
find it man just just find a way to
inspire our community and the people
around us and I think that that kind of
strength will also give us the strength
to be who we need to be every day to be
a successful for poking all right now
let's just spend a moment in the toy
department
out of the real-life world for second
Andrew Whitworth of the Los Angeles Rams
couldn't help but notice during the game
yesterday that a certain play call from
your quarterback Jared Goff was Halle
Berry Andrew and when I say couldn't
help but notice I also include Halle
Berry in that she tweeted catching that
what what is the play call Halle Berry
if best you can describe it without
giving away too much well you know what
I'll just say this we thought it was a
really beautiful play rich so you know
what what else would you call it than
Halle Berry so you know I think we can
all come to an agreement Halle Berry is
a beautiful human being and you know so
I you know hopefully she understands
it's a compliment
you know I think that's what the Jared
tried to let her know it's a beautiful
play and we're just glad that she
noticed it now if this is in fact Jared
shooting his shot Andrew is it him can
we give him full credit was he the one
who decided to to name this play this
beautiful play Halle Berry was it his
choice I don't actually know that it's
fact rich I'm pretty sure that that
might be the case but I don't actually
have a hundred percent fact on that so
I'm not gonna say that but hmm I will
say you know what hey good for him it's
though because you know he's a bachelor
here in Los Angeles right I mean that's
a way to get on somebody's radar screen
I imagine if you're the quarterback of
the Los Angeles Rams hey man you're 23
and the quarterback of the Rams and you
know having a great year I think you you
can get away with that okay and then in
terms of playing in this offense he said
it's my favorite play of the year is how
he responded to Howry Hallie and where
we're waiting to get a response to
should one be forthcoming from at Halle
Berry in terms of playing in this
offense you've played in a lot of
high-powered ones prior to the Rams what
is it like being in this offense coming
up where where so many inventive ideas
are being thrown in your direction and
you're being trusted to assimilate all
of it and execute it Andrew Whitworth
well I think there's just so much
precision that goes into what Sean wants
to do and he knows every play you can
see him visually so well that you know I
think that's really for us he's able to
describe and kind of ask us in a certain
way how to do things and I think that
the way he's able to kind of create the
picture we can see it too and I think
that's really what happens is that every
Sunday there's our place we really
honestly have a true belief that if
everyone just does it the exactly we
were coached to do it the way that Sean
is really giving it to the assistant
coaches to present to us then we have
full confidence that the plays work and
so it really just comes down to the
really the process more than a result
all week long we walk through step
through run these plays over and over
and over again
and kind of have a concept of exactly
how the defense's work and why these
plays should work and there's a full
belief that they will if we just do it
the way we were coached to do it and I
think when you're operating that well
that way that's what helps you have
success in this league is that
everyone's fully confident in their job
and doing it to a high level all right
Andrew before I let you go is it true
you donated game-worn jerseys to after
the game yesterday I don't know there's
so much going on I don't know which
where you've donated them where did you
donate game-worn jerseys from yesterday
how can people go ahead and bid on it to
raise money yeah the captain the all our
captains donated our jerseys after the
game we all signed them and people can
donate I believe on the Rams web site
they can go on there and donate our
auctions basically to bid for those and
yeah I mean just another way we can try
and do something and you know make a
difference I mean it's just important
like I said and adverse times rich
you'll never feel bad about just trying
to help in some way but if you sit there
and just worry about what you could do
and miss the moment you know that's
where you're messing up so we're just
trying to find any way we can to just be
active get our feet on the ground and be
involved and trying to be part of the
solution and I'm just proud of our team
and really just the effort guys have
made to do that
way to go Andrew Whitworth way to go man
and my best to your family and most
importantly as well your neighbors and
the first responders and the people
affected by the shooting and the way
that you and the rest of your teammates
have taken a leadership role in the
community that you've you're still new
to and and and best of luck on your
travels and I really appreciate you with
so much up in the air taking the time to
call into the show
you bet thank you that's Andrew
Whitworth one of the best at his job and
also one of the best people at his job
at Whitworth 77 if you want to give him
a follow on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience